hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einem fifa 17 wie die hat
mir gedacht die versetzung ist jetzt ja
auch schon ein halbes jahr draußen
deswegen sollte man fifa 17 her
deswegen habe ich mir hier ob es sind
zocker 2000 und wir schon unschwer
erkennen können steht die links player 1
und rechts player 2 deswegen habe ich
mir eine andere person dazu geholt und
zwar jetzt
ich kann auch so rangehen und dann hier
so ein bisschen über summen zu dir
geht's mir sagen dass der verlierer vom
anderen stelle kriegt ja ok wird es
nicht man sich doch man kann nicht mal
schießen das ist einfach wie vor 17
alter dass der neue unter dem baum back
to back to back wegduckt immer diese
landschaft drumherum kann der ball aus
18 sekunden drei tore zu machen mit 321
nur hinten was ist sein denn deine links
dann im statement zum erste niederlage
derzeit teste war ja das war ein fest
das ist eine taktik du stehst im tor
nein du willst als wenn wir keine
verfickte kacke rein
noch 50 sekunden 2000 jahre später dass
man dabei dass er schon seit 2000 jahren
einfach hinter drei sekunden sei ein was
ist dein statement zur zweiten
niederlage konnte auch beim vierten
schießen gaben um 1 kommt musst du musst
gewinde sonst kriegst du eine stelle das
sind hierfür spaß man zittert aber
lieben ihr 321 einfach ist das nicht
freude das letzte spiel dieses spiel
wird eine messe dieses spiel wird über
die städte entscheiden
von der seite nein nein nein
hühnerfrikassee ein bruder
als wenn junge ich habe jetzt drei
verloren hier das per video das heißt du
darfst der backpfeife gegeben
also lasst meine lieben freunde war es
mit diesem das war's mit diesem video
ist war total verplant aber ich habe da
nichts vor produziert ist gedacht wir
zocken fifa sitz hin wenns euch gefallen
hat würden wir zu einer bewertung freuen
meine wange tut irgendwie gar nicht
wählen danke wir sehen uns bei fifa 18
wieder nächste woche